speaking of death yeah there's a
fourteen-year-old girl in England who
she just recently passed but she had the
court system basic she had the courts
basically agree to carry out her death
wish which is to be like cryogen eyes
like to be cryogenically like to be
frozen and preserved so that down down
the road maybe she can be you know
revived in a different that happens all
the time no I know but a
fourteen-year-old girl she doesn't her
parents are responsible for her so it's
like usually you can make your own
choices as an adult but she couldn't and
her dad didn't agree to it but her mom
did so she has she went to court and the
court sided with her and said yeah like
her she had a disease she had cancer
she's now frozen yeah but then she had
her shed her body shipped to the United
States my question is this is that when
that happens like Walt Disney had that
done right yeah you know that yeah yeah
so how do you know that they're gonna
defrost you one time is the time when
does it happen when the time is right
yes so a thousand years later some guy
that works at the company goes I guess
this is the time no but it's as a
14-year old dying and you never really
had too much time on earth I think you
just want a second shot at anywhere
anytime saddest thing wasn't me cross
that why'd you bring that up because
it's real it's so sad yeah 14 years and
did you ever fold over how do you know
we know you didn't make it up well then
I got one then two you've no photos no
twelve-year-old boy oh I get lupus oh no
right but severely and he was growing
into his brain
okay lupus is an autoimmune disorder
doesn't grow what is whom where this one
did okay and his name was Rafael okay
and he he believes him that if he was
buried on the moon that's gonna preserve
his body so he is on the moon now being
preserved do you have a picture no but I
believe yeah it probably isn't a photo
she's a minor
no do you just make [ __ ] up and it
really makes me [ __ ] angry about
remember the poop pills you didn't
believe that people actually like yeah
see this yeah but you had photos of it
no no don't believe me if I google poop
pills it's gonna take I have photos if I
google 14 or go cry generic whatever
really frozen
[Music]